top thema heute hilfe mein lockdown wird
schon wieder hart ja vielleicht schon ab
nächster woche kommt der harte lockt
also salzmann sich auf eine einheitliche
strategie einigt die vielleicht sogar
mal länger als drei tage hält kann ja
sein lockdown neidhardt medium rare man
kommt gar nicht mehr nach es hilft ja
alles nix es hilft nichts bei den zahlen
müssen wir wohl fast alles nicht machen
fällt der politik spät genug ein aber
jetzt muss es halt sehr schnell gehen
der lock down muss schnellstmöglichst
kommen wir brauchen schnellstmöglich
einen lock down in ganz deutschland wir
müssen schnell handeln so schnell wie
möglich jetzt handeln schneller kommen
schnell handeln schnellstmöglich heißt
auch schnellstmöglich ach so gut zu
wissen anke armin heute konnten sich die
superschnellen landeschefs übrigens erst
mal stundenlang auf keinen konferenz
termin einigen ja die wollten
wahrscheinlich alle noch mal schnell
shoppen gehen bevor sie die läden
zumachen jetzt ist konsequenz gefragt
statt symbolpolitik
ich sag nur nächtliche ausgangssperre in
bayern ja so was klingt erstmal
vollhardt aber wer will denn bei dem
wetter nach 21 uhr überhaupt noch vor
die tür wo alle kneipen zu haben ja gut
vampire geschenkt fakt ist die zahlen
müssen jetzt runter weil man den sommer
verpennt hat bund und länder hätten
längst viel mehr ffb zwei masken einen
risikopatienten verteilen müssen viel
mehr investieren sollen für schnelltests
oder für luftreiniger in schulen
da sitzen die kinder immer noch beim
lüften im durchzug immerhin gab es diese
woche kostenlose tipps und man muss sich
vielleicht wirklich ein bisschen was
wärmeres noch zum anziehen mitbringen
vielleicht macht man auch mal eine
kleine kniebeuge oder so oder klatscht
in die hände damit man ein bisschen warm
wird kinder aerobic mitteilte angela wie
schön
passend dazu rät ihr kanzleramtsminister
helge braun menschen die sich morgens
auf dem weg zur arbeit sorgen machen
wegen der vollen busse fahrt doch
einfach hart sagte er
oder klatscht in die hände adventszeit
und in einem altenheim ist besuchsverbot
dann mach doch einfach kniebeugen und
klatscht in die hände
sofort ist man weniger einsam
alleinerziehend und schon wieder
homeschooling ein kleiner tipp
kniebeugen helfen immer besonders
zusammen mit händeklatschen mal wieder
14 stunden schicht im schon vor jahren
kaputt gesparten krankenhaus weißt du
was du jetzt brauchst genau
sofort geht es dir besser ab gern
geschehen
deine bundesregierung
wenn's hilft mir tun vor allem lehrer
leitet die immer noch kein wlan in ihrer
schule haben aber jetzt trotzdem wieder
digital unterricht machen soll
weil die neue homeschooling saison
offensichtlich vor der tür steht konnte
ja keiner ahnen
außerdem sagt man gar nicht mehr
homeschooling und die schulen in sachsen
zb werden auch gar nicht geschlossen
nicht die schulen werden geschlossen
sondern es wird eine häusliche lernzeit
geben ab montag in der kommenden woche
so nix homeschooling häusliche lernzeit
klingt gleich viel schöner
sachsens ministerpräsident tillich noch
der lockersten lockerer von allen sagt
jetzt wir haben dieses virus
unterschätzt alle miteinander ja alle
wirklich ja natürlich wo hätte man denn
wissen wollen was diesen winter passiert
es wusste ja keiner hier interview aus
dem april
und wir zählen auch spaß mal mit was
alles eingetreten ist vielleicht kommen
wir damit glimpflich über den sommer
haben aber immer noch wenig bevölkerungs
immunität und laufen dann mit einer
immunologischen naiven bevölkerung in
einem winter welle rein
darauf müsste man sich vorbereiten das
wäre gefährlich und man müsste dann auch
sich darauf einstellen dass man wieder
in den lockdown gehen muss im winter ja
ganz gute trefferquote gibt den posten
der sendung bei astrotv so viel zum
thema politik hört auf wissenschaft
manchmal in kanada hat die fans gegen
reisewelle die bewohner zahlen gerade
explodieren lassen
steht uns das nach weihnachten
vielleicht auch bevor hier der chef der
bundespolizei mit einem sehr langen witz
ich werde häufiger gefragt welches
reisemittel sicherer ist das auto das
schiff der flugzeug die eisenbahn
da ich nun mal für alle
grenzüberschreitenden verkehre zuständig
bin antworte ich regelmäßig das sofa
schöne geschichte die da war ich halt
mit dem sofa
natürlich muss sich jeder von uns auch
an die eigene nase fassen
erwachsene verhalten sich vor lauter
pandemie müdigkeit wie zwölfjährige ich
darf alles machen was nicht explizit
verboten ist
niemand zwingt uns an verkaufsoffenen
sonntagen in übervolle einkaufszentren
zu rennen oder anja ist das glühwein
wanderung teilzunehmen so wie hier in
berlin am prenzlauer berg spricht man
erst hat schon vom glühwein strich wird
natürlich jetzt auch alles wieder
verboten obwohl keiner weiß ob sich da
leute anstecken
deswegen wäre es gerechter für ein paar
wochen alles dicht zu machen was jetzt
wohl passiert selbst ökonomen sagen dass
es billiger als ein teil shutdown leid
bis in den frühling
aber dann kommt ja das licht am
tunnelende der impfstoff und zwar wie es
aussieht erst mal monatelang für
risikopatienten und für senioren wissen
sie eigentlich was das bedeutet das
bedeutet unsere älteren mitbürger können
schon anfang nächsten jahres direkt nach
der impfung wieder party machen in
kneipen und bars jungen rocken dann noch
zu hause und die feiern hat ab heisst
oma und opa haben endlich die clubs für
sich alleine
es sei ihm gegönnt warum das ist die
große frage hat man den menschen hier
überhaupt hoffnung auf ein lockeres
weihnachten gemacht und was wenn das
jetzt nicht kommt fragen wie man den
mann der wenn es blöd läuft seinen
geburtstag nicht richtig feiern kann uns
live zugeschaltet ist jesus jesus macht
ihnen das sorgen nee wirklich nicht
dieses ganze weihnachtszeit ist ja
inzwischen völlig aus dem ruder gelaufen
der ganze konsumterror
wir schenken uns hier oben seit jahren
nur noch kleinigkeiten playstation fünf
macbook pro das reicht doch völlig zu
meinem ersten geburtstag habe ich ja
noch weihrauch und myrrhe kriegen weiß
bis heute nicht was das ist hier in
deutschland dürfen wir ihren geburtstag
vielleicht mit bis zu zehn personen
feiern völliger wahnsinn
das müsst ihr meinen wegen echt nicht
machen heiligabend gibt es bei uns
kartoffelsalat und würstchen damit meine
frau weniger arbeit hat danach
vielleicht ein schönes brettspiel oder
keine ahnung zusammen coole musik hören
mal ernsthaft was ihr da macht ist
quatsch mit zehn leuten feiern ist ja in
meinem geburtstag nicht ungefährlicher
als an silvester das geht nicht
ich musste sogar meinen vater auslagen
weil der risikogruppe ist sorry papa ist
einfach zu gefährlich dürfen sprung
[Musik]
schaffen klar hast du das siehst du ja
ok aber bis nächstes jahr tut mir auch
weh
also sie plädieren für den harten
lockdown er sich nur die harten kommen
garten eden
er ist echt mal mehr auf den dings hören
wie heißt er dieser alttestamentarische
untergangspropheten immer bei land sitzt
leider war er ist gut
ihr deutschen jammert mir zu schieben
seine grundrechte ich muss bei lidl
maske tragen ja und waren sie mal bei
einer kreuzigung dabei hat sich so noch
nicht ergeben
ohne klare ansagen geht's nicht
natürlich ist es schöner wenn die leute
von alleine vernünftig sind aber sind
sie halt nicht so und jetzt muss ich
schluss machen ich habe kundschaft an
einem glühweinstand
ein abend einmal wie immer mit schuss
macht 4 80 bis 5 euro pfand jesus meine
damen und herren
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]